from Kendall Jenner's booty to Celine  Dion's dance party to Katy Perry's epic  performance et has your exclusive look  inside the 2017 Met Gala stars were out  in full force Monday night in New York  City for fashions biggest night Katy  Perry who was this year's co-chair  alongside Anna Wintour and Pharrell  Williams performed during the event in  this black latex get up for the a-list  crowd which included Selena Gomez the  weekend  Gwyneth Paltrow and more Celine Dion was  spotted dancing up a storm with Halle  Berry and Kendall Jenner kept on  flaunting that booty it looks like  rumored beau ASAP rocky even copped a  feel  meanwhile Ryan Reynolds Hugh Jackman and  Jake Gyllenhaal were all smiles hanging  together this is a bro-down  reeling a tribe erotic Hollywood's elite  were seen hugging their famous friends  smelling the Roses and even taking  bathroom selfies what a fabulous night  [Music]  you